so we've just talked about randomized
algorithms but we can look at
the probabilistic analysis of algorithms
and
that gives us an opportunity to step
back and as we said
everything we've been talking about is
worst case analysis right
could you maybe comment on
the usefulness and the power of worst
case analysis versus
best case analysis average case
probabilistic how do we think about the
future of theoretical computer science
computer science
in the kind of analysis we do of
algorithms does worst case analysis
still have a place
an important place or do we want to try
to move forward towards kind of average
case analysis yeah
and what what are the challenges there
so if worst case analysis
shows that an algorithm is always good
that's fine uh if worst case analysis
is used to show that the problem
that the solution is not always good
then you have to step back and do
something else
to ask how often will you get a good
solution
just to pause on that for a second that
that's so uh beautifully put
because i think we tend to judge
algorithms
we throw them in the trash the moment
their
their worst case is shown to be bad
right and and
and that's unfortunate i think we um
a good example is um going back to the
satisfiability problem
um there are very powerful programs
called sat solvers
which in practice fairly reliably
solve instances with many millions of
variables that arise in
digital design or improving programs
correct and other applications
and so in in many application areas even
though satisfiability as we've
already discussed is npe complete
um the sat solvers will work so well
that the people in that discipline tend
to think of satisfiability as an easy
problem
so in other words just
for some reason that we don't entirely
understand
the instances that people formulate in
designing digital circuits or other
applications
are such that um
satisfiability is not hard to check
and even searching for a satisfying
solution can be done efficiently
in practice and there are
many examples for example we talked
about the traveling salesman problem
so just to refresh our memories uh the
problem is you've got a set of cities
you have
pairwise distances between cities
um and you want to find a tour through
all the cities that
minimizes the total the total cost of
all the edges traversed
all all the trips between cities the
problem is
np hard but people using
integer programming codes
together with some other mathematical
tricks
can solve
geometric instances of the problem where
the cities are let's say points in the
plane
and get optimal solutions to problems
with tens of thousands of cities
actually it'll take a few computer
months to
solve a problem of that size but for
problems of size a thousand or two
it'll rapidly get optimal solutions
provably optimal solutions even though
again
we know that it's unlikely
that the traveling salesman problem can
be solved in polynomial time
are there methodologies like rigorous
systematic methodologies
for you said
in practice in practice this algorithm
is pretty good are there systematic ways
of
saying in practice this runs pretty good
so in other words average case analysis
or you've also mentioned that average
case
kind of requires you to understand what
the typical cases
typical instances and that might be
really difficult that's very difficult
so after i did my original work
on getting
showing all these problems through enp
complete
i looked around for a way to get some
shed some positive light on
combinatorial algorithms
and what i tried to do was to study um
problems behavior on the average or
with high probability but i had to make
some assumptions about
what what's the probability space what's
the sample space what do they
what do we mean by typical problems
that's very hard to say
so i took the easy way out and made some
very simplistic assumptions
so i assumed for example that if we were
generating a graph
with a certain number of vertices and
edges
then we would generate the graph by
simply choosing one edge at a time
at ran at random until we got the right
number of edges
that's that's a particular model of
random graphs that has been studied
mathematically a lot
and within that model i i could prove
all kinds of wonderful things
i and others who also worked on this
so we could show that we know
exactly how many edges there have to be
in order for
um there be a
so-called hamiltonian circuit that's a
cycle that
visits each vertex exactly once
um we know that if the
number of edges is a little bit more
than n log n
where n is the number of vertices then
where
such a cycle is very likely to exist
and we can give a heuristic that will
find it with her high probability
and we got a uh the community
um in which i was working got a lot of
results
along these lines but
the field tended to be rather
lukewarm about accepting these results
as meaningful
because we were making such a simplistic
assumption about the kinds of graphs
that we would be dealing with so we
could show all kinds of wonderful things
it was a great playground i enjoyed
doing it
but after a while i
concluded that um um
that it didn't have a lot of bite in
terms of the practical application
oh the okay so there's too much into the
world of toy problems
yeah that can okay but all right
but is is there a way to find
nice representative real world impactful
instances of a problem on which
demonstrate
that an algorithm is good so this is
kind of like the machine learning world
that's kind of what they at his best
tries to do is
find a data set from like the real world
and show the performance all the
all the conferences are all focused on
beating the performance
of on that real world data set is there
an equivalent
in the complexity analysis
not really um don knuth
started to collect examples of graphs
coming from various places so he would
have a whole
zoo of different graphs that he could
choose from and he
could study the performance of
algorithms on different types of graphs
and um but there it's really important
and
and compelling to be able to define
a class of graphs so that
the actual act of defining a class of
graphs that you're interested in
it seems to be um a non-trivial step
before talking about
instances that we should care about in
the real world yeah
it's there's nothing available there
that
would be analogous to the training set
for supervised learning
you know where you sort of assume that
the world has
given you a bunch of uh examples uh
to work with uh we don't really have
that for
problems for combinatorial problems on
graphs and networks
you know there's been a huge growth a
big growth of data sets
available do you think some aspect of
theoretical computer science
might be contradicting my own question
while saying it but
will there be some aspect an empirical
aspect of theoretical computer science
which will allow the fact that these
datasets are huge we'll start using them
for analysis
sort of you know if you want to say
something about
a graph algorithm you might take
a net on a social network like facebook
yeah and looking at subgraphs of that
and prove
something about the facebook graph and
be respected
and at the same time be respected in the
theoretical computer science community
that hasn't been achieved yet i'm afraid
is that
is that uh is it p equals np is that
impossible
is it impossible to publish a successful
paper in the theoretical computer
science community
that shows some
uh some performance on a real world data
set or is that really just those are two
different worlds
well they haven't really come together i
would say that there is
a field of experimental algorithmics
where people sometimes they're given uh
some family of examples
sometimes they just generate them at
random and they
report on performance
but there's no convincing
evidence that the sample is
representative of anything at all
you